good morning it's always interesting the
night the morning after the party it's
like a little bit more quiet in the room
and people are just sitting there like
oh
scroll scroll on their phones so um i
hope you enjoyed that party um if you
enjoyed it a bit too much try to find
some energy to get it through this talk
because it's going to be high pace i
have a whole bunch of takeaways um
i honestly haven't counted them because
well the length of the talk always
varies so the number of takeaways does
as well we're going to talk about api
security when i talk about a whole bunch
of things that go wrong
and i'm going to talk about a whole
bunch of ways to fix those problems of
going wrong i'm going to show you how
they come into existence and what we can
do to actually counter them and what i
would really like to happen at the end
of this talk i'm going to mention that
again is that you'll you'll take the
takeaways from this this slide you'll
recognize from this presentation you'll
recognize them by the slide format and
really take them to heart take them with
you to your company and start applying
those principles on your apis sooner
rather than later all right
let's dive right in with a study on api
security from last year from 30
healthcare apps in the uk and the study
found that healthcare apps got kind of
sensitive data by design i mean they
should have
security kind of on a high level and it
shows that that's really really not the
case so of these 30 popular apps 77
contained hard-coded api keys and that
means if you put a secret in an app and
you deploy it on a phone somebody's
going to take that binary file run some
tools on it and find your secrets
allowing them to abuse that and seven
percent even contained hard-coded
usernames and passwords which goes as
far as full database access usernames
and passwords which is kind of like an
oopsie if you want to call it that
that's absolutely horrible and that's
something we talk about the first thing
you learn when you learn about mobile
security and and client-side security is
like never ever ever put secrets on the
client and it's actually worse because
the the study also looked at apis behind
these apps and they found that of the
apis they looked at they haven't tested
all apis but of the apis they tested
every single one of them had
authorization problems every single one
of them
and that brings me to the first takeaway
of this presentation yes it goes that
fast first takeaway the cowboy years are
over as in
we can't keep doing this this is
absolutely unsustainable if we keep
handling security like an afterthought
like oh yeah we'll look at security when
we have some time and money in the
future that's not gonna work
it simply doesn't work you have to look
at security from the start you have to
build up your security
mechanisms your culture your your skill
set basically and start ensuring
security from day one
and that's something that's that's
actually changing and that's a good
thing because my customers are usually
or used to be very big companies like
established security programs and money
to throw around for consultants and so
on and so on and these days i often work
with startups
startups that don't even have a product
out they just secured some funding and
they're like okay now we can do security
before we even have our first customer
because we know that we won't be able to
do it afterwards and that's the right
attitude and that's
definitely a good starting point
all right
that's just to get you warmed up i'm
philippe drake from belgium and i run my
own company called pragmatic web
security and if you're in my talk
yesterday you've heard this pitch so you
can go rest for one minute and recover
from the party otherwise you might be
interested to learn that i help other
people build more secure software so i
provide knowledge on security through
training consulting online courses and
so on and i also organized a course in
belgium called sec update which is one
week about
application security taught by people
from all over the world it's like a
conference but longer and more in-depth
and um
absolutely awesome so if you are ever
interested in visiting belgium we have
good beers by the way if you're into
that
then you might want to
convince your boss to send you the
second dev that would be great all right
back at
api security api security is a big thing
right well everybody's doing api so kind
of logically that api security becomes
more important we even have a dedicated
os top then for api security and if you
look at the os stop then
you might get a little bit depressed
actually because a lot of these issues
are about authorization and
authentication almost 40
and if you depends on how you count if
you include authentication as well 50 of
the top 10 are about authorization and
authentication issues that's massive
i also see that there's a bunch of
overlap between the os
api security top 10 and the traditional
web application security top then like
there's some overlap injection is still
there a problem that we've been dealing
with for 25 years is still unsolved in
apis which is again unsurprising because
apis are just a different way of
building an application
based on this stop then you can kind of
imagine i'm going to talk about
authentication and authorization a bit
today but before we do that i want to
talk about number four lack of resources
and rate limiting and i want to talk
about this because
it's
it's kind of a weird issue that that is
often under recognized people are like
oh yeah sure denial of service that's
that's important we we need to protect
against denial of service attacks and
yes that's true and if you think about
the now service like filling up the
network connection so you become
unreachable or abusing cpu or memory of
your application so it becomes
unavailable sure that's a problem if
it's not available you likely lose money
have unhappy customers and so on and so
on but to me it's not the biggest
security issue that you can have in your
applications and if you start thinking
about this issue there's actually a
whole bunch more that goes on there
that's often just
brushed over or forgotten or not even
considered for example what about
abusing application features
would it be the first time facebook had
this problem in a bunch of their apis
where you could reset your password and
if you reset a password they send you a
six digit code over a text message or an
email and you have to enter that six
digit code and then you can choose a new
password and they forgot
to implement rate limiting on that
endpoint
well actually they didn't forget they
had rate limiting on the endpoint 10 12
attempts and you were out done
but they also had a beta api
available publicly without that
mechanism so somebody figured it out
like hey that's the same endpoint allows
me to recover my account on the beta api
and they don't have rate limiting so it
doesn't take too long to guess a six
digit recovery code with brute force
lack of rate limiting just like that
abusing legitimate application features
exceeding usage restrictions we all know
these plans where you purchase the basic
planning you get like 10 10 operations
per minute or whatever you're doing well
those things need to be enforced and
many apis well actually this is
something they actually get right
because that's kind of their business
model so they do enforce users
restrictions quite often in the right
way but that's also the same issue
often not considered and finally we have
large scale exploitation what happens
if i abuse another vulnerability an
authorization problem allowing me to
access all the data in your application
all the documents
why do we hear about data breaches where
somebody downloaded like 100 million
documents from an api and nobody even
noticed that something was wrong
well if you would have had some rate
limiting in place some detection
mechanisms some limits sensible limits
maybe the attack would have been cut off
at one million hundred thousand thousand
whatever you're doing so all of these
things
fall under that same category so it's
more than just denial of service that's
the takeaway here it's a lot more than
just preventing somebody from taking
down your system which is the only thing
we often look at it's much more about
enforcing sensible limits and building
this
logical way of approaching these
these problems so that's the issue
how do you do that well
i can go into a lot of depth which i'm
not going to do here so i'm going to
give you an overview of different
strategies you can follow
and i'll give you a teaser for the
takeaway after this section that the
takeaway is going to be combine these
strategies into something that makes
sense for you there's no
one-size-fits-all solution it's always
going to be like do this in combination
with this and this and together you may
have a robust defense against
high volume or large-scale attacks
first thing is the common one that's
what everybody thinks about like yeah
infrastructure limits and um computation
limits like you can put restrictions on
your docker containers and somebody can
only consume this much memory instead of
bringing down the whole server yes those
things are absolutely useful use them as
a defense against hoarding resources
basically
something much more trivial
is application level input validation
very often applications have features
where you can specify an amount that you
expect as a result so a pagination
feature like oh yeah page seven uh ten
ten items well if somebody asks for page
seven with a million items some systems
are like okay sure if that's what you
want bam and they take themselves out
just by trying to fetch the information
from the database
having input validation there like a
value between 10 and 100 is acceptable
and rejecting everything else that's a
good first step it's trivial and it's
not it's not fun and sexy to build
things like that but it's something
that's really really important to apply
and practice
offloading
that's the best one because it it takes
some responsibility away from you if you
offload something you can basically be
like
now that's your problem you deal with it
that's what we do when you use open id
connect you offload or saml for that
matter no when you use when you use open
id connect you offload authentication to
an identity provider which can be a
service you pay and then you tell them
like an odd0 like that's your problem
you deal with user authentication and
password recovery and all of that stuff
i don't have to worry about that anymore
it also goes for untrustworthy features
like authentication very sensitive but
untrustworthy things like image
processing you get an image and you have
to make a thumbnail out of it well if
something goes wrong it's going to be
that thing that goes wrong there's all
kinds of ways that can go wrong offload
that to an additional a separate service
something you can build yourself and
deploy yourself sure but
compartmentalize it isolate it in case
something does go wrong it's only that
small component that has a problem it
doesn't affect the rest of your system
your apis and your data
and then finally application specific
rate limiting is very useful as well
those are things relevant to your
application have like a global catch-all
like we only allow this many requests
per second per user something like that
or in the graphql world we have limiting
query depth of a graphql query or even
calculating the cost of a query look at
github that's a very good example github
has a whole documentation page saying
like if you send us a graphql query this
is how we calculate the cost and you get
this many
cost factors i don't know what they call
it per month or per hour or whatever and
after that we cut you off and that gives
you a way to estimate like okay the
query i'm going to make is going to be
this expensive and i have this much
budget left so yes i can do that or
maybe i shouldn't do that
those things really matter and the true
defenses combination of all of these
things together like compartmentalizing
putting things separate making someone
else responsible for that having some
sensible limits having solid
input sanitization input validation
strong limits on the application all of
that is going to be your defense against
os api security top 10 number four which
is
lack of resources and rate limiting
all right
what about the client let's talk about
bumble bumble is a dating app
and
like many apps they have this this
freemium model right they entice you
into signing up for their service and
then they impose the limits and they try
to trick you or convince you let's call
it convince you to buy the paid version
of the application
and their goal is to
help you find a match which is kind of
against their business model so i'm not
sure how that works but
their goal is essentially to to have you
find a match in life and they had some
limits on the free version and it turns
out that those limits were largely
enforced on the client so somebody
looked at the client app and said like
oh i can only swipe 10 times per day or
something unless i pay them money to do
more but the api never enforces things
so if you analyze the api calls from the
client you can intercept them you can
monitor them and send them out again you
could keep doing whatever you're doing
same thing with having access to locked
features if an account was locked for
some reason the front end said like oh
you the client you can't access the
application anymore but the api was like
me i don't care
just a mirror gus i'll do it anyway
sure it takes some skill to be able to
do that but that way you could get free
access to bumble's premium features
which it's very illegal by the way so
you shouldn't do that
just as an example
and this happens everywhere so this is
an example from twitter a couple years
ago twitter had this brain fart called
fleets um which was around for like a
few months and then they said like yeah
this was not a very good idea so they
killed it again but it was around long
enough
for somebody to look into that and they
enforce transactional integrity on the
clients like they fetched a temporary
fleet and then they send a read
notification to the api like okay the
user has read this
which of course all means that an
attacker could stop that
read notification they would get all the
information without the other person or
twitter knowing that that was
information was consumed which is again
not how things are supposed to work they
also had things disappear after a while
that's the whole point of temporary data
it disappears but the client just didn't
show it anymore the api still returned
the data if you knew how to get it which
is again not how things are supposed to
go
what i'm aiming at here
is that the client is irrelevant for
security
and this is a very very very common
problem in api security that people
often consider the client and the api
together
that's what your quality assurance team
is going to look at they're going to
look at the client like can i swipe more
than 10 times oh no it's blocked good
check what else do we need to have for
so this let's test it out oh it works
cool
but what people often forget is that an
attacker can bypass the client because
they control the device they control the
network traffic they can easily
intercept that there's plenty of tools
for that
inspect the api requests and send
whatever they want
restrictions from the client are useless
when it comes to security same thing for
hidden api endpoints
oh it's hidden the client doesn't use it
nobody knows it except our admin client
like yeah awesome security
not really because attackers literally
have dictionary lists of common api
endpoints and they just load a list in a
tool like burp and they hammer your api
and they get a 404 404 500 like ooh
interesting and they have found your
hidden api endpoint
so you can't hide these things in
practice somebody will find it and
somebody will abuse it and that's your
attack surface every endpoint you expose
is your attack surface that's what you
have to look at
when you secure your api
when i talk about this
on a moment not after the party people
are often more responsive like hey hold
on hold on are client controls really
useless like isn't that good user
experience to enforce things on the
client it's like yes it is
good
this was a very short-sighted takeaway
it's it's not complete yet i have to
nuance this a little bit so yes client
controls are useless for a user
experience if the user is not supposed
to access a feature don't offer them
access in the ui that's a common
principle that's good
and it goes even further i would say
mimic all the checks you do in your api
mimic them in the client input
validation on feels like hey this field
can only contain these values and force
that in the client
and in the api
same thing with authorization
and that gives you a very useful feature
because if you enforce that in the
clients in legitimate behavior
how often should those controls fail on
the api side for legitimate use cases
never never
thank you
did you go to the party sir
i tried to leave a bit early yeah that
explains that explains
awesome
seriously your api controls shouldn't
fail if the client enforces the same
controls and if they fail well
in my case i probably have messed up the
client that's how things go but in other
cases
it's typically someone messing with your
api
if you all of a sudden get invalid data
that it can there's no way that can pass
through the client and somebody's
messing with a network request and
seeing what your api does when they send
you malformed data malicious data and
that allows you to raise alerts now you
can monitor the behavior like what the
hell is this user doing
like oh they're trying this ah that
doesn't work they're trying that
oh crap they're sending this we haven't
thought about that and now you can
follow up on that and fix it or you can
block the user you can divert them to
100 whatever works for you so the
takeaway isn't that the client is
useless for security but the client is
irrelevant to enforce security you can't
enforce restrictions on the client alone
but if you do it at both places then you
get high confidence alerts that somebody
is sending malicious data to your api
and that information is very useful for
your security team to follow up on
potential attacks
all right
back to the dating scene
grinder just like so many applications
has user accounts email address password
and people forget their passwords that's
how that goes there's a talk about
passwords later today i think so you
might want to go there to learn how to
make passwords a bit more manageable
at this point we're not there yet so
what happens when you forgot your
password you enter an email address like
philippe grammatic websecurity.com you
hit the button reset password and you
get an email with the secret token in
the url and you click it and you choose
a new password that's how these things
work right
and that's exactly how grinder worked
and the response so that the front ends
you enter emails sends a request and
gets a response from the api and the
response to contain json data and part
of that data was the email address from
the front can show you we send an email
to flip
fragmaticwebsecurity.com awesome
and that that's all what the front-end
did but the api response contained the
second field
password reset token
that secret token that's only supposed
to be in that email because it allows
you to choose a new password was
returned as json data in the response
and you don't see it
called the assurance team the testing
team was like yeah this works awesome
until you look at the response data open
up a network tool and look at the actual
json it's like oh crap that's not good
because now you can go there enter my
email address look at the json response
get my token fill it out in the url and
choose a new password and do god knows
what my account
don't tell my wife about that
all right
this is called sensitive data exposure
and it's really common because it's an
absolutely invisible vulnerability
unless you look at the network traffic
here's the api security swag shop which
is very fictional but whatever there's a
list of online users which is probably
not very gdpr compliant but i'm going to
leave that in the middle and that list
of users comes from an api response with
json data and the front-end just picks
whatever it needs and ignores all the
rest that's how these things work
and you can see that there's a bunch of
shipping addresses there that probably
shouldn't be there and that you might
want to hide in your api responses
that's sensitive data exposure oasp api
security top 10 number
anybody
nobody paying attention no
no photographic memory number three
it's that common number three it's like
authorization issues authentication
issues like oh crap sensitive data
exposure it's everywhere it's really
everywhere and here's how that happens
it happens because
we are spoiled as developers
seriously because frameworks do
everything for us this is an example
from spring like a really simple example
on top we get a list of users we fetch
that list from god knows where in the
system and we return a list of users by
calling on line four a new response
response entity just like that
you throw a bunch of java objects in
there and spring is like oh okay then
i'm gonna make that into json for you
because nobody wants to write json by
hand if you've ever done that
you never want to do that ever again
especially if you have to start escaping
double quotes and it's like an absolute
freaking nightmare so middleware does
that for us jackson in the spring java
case
and that has the same and python has the
same and ruby has the same and they all
do that because nobody ever wants to do
that by hand ever again and what happens
is if you have a data class like the
user it contains that's your model
that's what you use in your application
it contains all of these fields and this
the json translator here will be like
fields json bam bam and audit goes just
like that
code code example on top vulnerable to
sensitive data exposure it's that simple
really common
so how do we fix it
well i have two solutions one crappy one
and one
annoying but better one
the crappy solution is by marking things
as json ignore
that's always the easy solution like oh
this field should not be exposed let's
just slap an annotation on there and the
parser or the json translator will
ignore that awesome
good the problem is you have to go
through all of your data classes and
mark every field you do not want to
expose as json ignore and if you forget
one
you have a problem
a wasp.net number three sensitive data
exposure check
well that's the bad checklist not a good
checklist so this works but i don't like
it i don't like having to go through all
of these things and remember that and if
you forget one it becomes a problem so
the better solution
is using this very old pattern called
dtos data transfer objects where we
basically translate that user object
that internal concept into something
that we that has better semantics like
the public user info class
and if you complain about a verbosity of
dtos well you're doing java so you have
no right to complain at all
this is just inherent nature to java
but seriously this has proper semantics
if you now look at the code it says like
okay what do we return oh public user
info awesome what's public user info
idea name very easy very clear to see
and very hard to make a mistake yes you
can still add a sensitive address feel
to that public user info class but it's
going to be much more difficult to make
that mistake by accident
probably don't write it right after the
party wait until tomorrow to update
something like that but seriously if you
make that mistake it's going to be very
much more obvious than before
this is sensitive data exposure
and this
automatic marshalling between json and
other formats like java objects well
java objects and json results in a very
interesting question if we can trick an
api or if an api automatically exposes
data by accident
what if we can make it accept data by
accident
wouldn't that be awesome
or what's the api security top 10 number
six mass assignment mass assignment is
the same problem in the other way around
now we submit more json than the
application actually expects
and override fields in internal user
objects here's how that works another
crappy spring security our spring boot
code example on top we online two we
request
we
accept a request to update a user user's
data and we accept user information
and we use that user information to
update the user object in the system
which will result in updating the
database and so on and so on
and here's our user class so we have an
id and name and a role in the system
like employee or admin or whatever and
here's the json that's the
that part that's the red part that's how
we update the database and here's the
json to update my name to dr phil easy
straightforward you test this out you
enter the field in the app you submit it
and it works and everybody's happy
awesome
until the attacker comes around the
attacker it's like hmm
what if i provide data like this i
provide you a name and a role and that
role gets picked up by well it gets
translated from json into a user object
gets sent to the database layer it
updates all the fields and bam now i
became an admin
seems simple on a slide it's like oh
yeah
of course
happens in real world systems results in
account takeover all kinds of really
nasty vulnerabilities just because of
mass assignment
awesome right thank you chase and
translators i mean
how do we fix it well
this is kind of history repeating we can
use annotations to tell that jason
parson like yeah this field should not
be set from jason it's read only so you
can expose it but not accept it
again same problems here you have to do
this for every field and i don't really
like it as in
it's too hard to make a mistake here for
getting one annotation and you have a
vulnerability
so why don't we use again a dto class
like this one where we have update user
info and we only provide a name field
there's no way to smuggle additional
json into this approach and it kind of
solves the problem by design yes it
takes a little bit more effort but it's
really really worth it
and the takeaway here is
it's kind of more general let's test
your apis in their natural habitat
because these issues often only become
apparent if you start testing them in
real world systems because this might
not always occur in development systems
it may not occur if you're not using the
real real api to test certain things if
you have a bunch of limited tests so
test them
in
a running condition test them as you
would deploy them
and make sure you can find these
vulnerabilities
in practice
all right
great way to follow up that takeaway
like test your apis and then it's
testing really good
well maybe the answer is yes for once
it isn't
it's kind of a giveaway when i add in
trainings as well when i ask something
people are like yeah it's not going to
be yes so probably no and
of course then the question is why why
not
in this case it's unsustainable you
can't keep testing all api endpoints yes
you can do that a couple of times and
you can write some tests but this is not
something that's going to work well
reliably towards the future this doesn't
scale very well
so what can we do there well
there's this cool thing called open api
specification or swagger the old version
and it basically allows you to define
the exact behavior you expect from your
apis like a full contract like hey this
endpoint will return application slash
json content types and the schema of
that looks like it's an array of items
and those area contains objects and
objects have an id and a name no address
field
awesome well not really it's yaml so
it's a pain in the ass to ride it's like
space base base space entertainment
you also have the json version which
isn't better by the way so it's it's
absolutely horrible but there's tool
support tools allow you to easily
specify this there's ways to add this to
your code so you don't have to have a
separate specification file you can just
add it as comments in the code and
generate documentation straight from
this that's awesome you can generate
docs from this
like literally generate docs boom here's
a full html website with api
documentation
cool
you can use this as a communication tool
between teams
ever had the discussion between
frontlines and apis like yeah this
returns something like this and then it
turns out it's something completely
different and everything breaks when you
integrate them well not with an api
contract
you have tools that can
use this as input and provide very
useful features for testing but also for
security
for example there's tools to find
authorization vulnerabilities give it a
contract and they will start hammering
your api with requests that respect the
contract but do something slightly
different to see how it responds
and there's another tool from microsoft
as well and more advanced tools
there's api firewalls that can take a
contract as input and inspect requests
as they see them go by and responses go
back and it can be like mass assignment
a request with additional json like hey
the contract doesn't allow this
it either blocks the request or removes
the data or whatever and the same thing
for responses sensitive data exposure
like oh crap we have five additional
fields being exposed and the current
success only three like no no let's not
do that let's strip them or block the
response or whatever we want to do as a
response that api contract enables
security so you have to start using it
who here is using it who's using open
api
about half of the room
when i'm back
in september i'm going to be at ndc oslo
and you're here as well i expect the
whole room to be like oh yeah we're
using it
and give your honest feedback oh we hate
it that's perfectly valid i mean that's
absolutely fine but seriously this is
the future security tools are consuming
this and it's going to get used more
often everywhere it's really really
powerful it's just a little bit of
effort to write it and keep it up to
date but it's really worth it in the end
all right
that brings us to the mobile
well
i've been using these slides for a long
time it's from 2017 this article
since then they have a couple of had a
couple of more preachers but uh i'm not
going to talk about those here
what happened here t-mobile allows you
to fetch your account information
like so many applications like hey i
want to see my account info send a
request and the identifier for your
account is your phone number
because that's kind of a unique
identifier so
that kind of works out well no need to
generate a new id we'll just use the
phone number easy so i send a request to
the api and i with my phone number and i
get my account information awesome
and i send a request with your phone
number and i get your account
information
not awesome not good that's what
happened here
this is a problem that has been around
i don't know the exact date i haven't
looked it up for at least two decades
if not longer it used to be called
insecure direct object references
because that a phone number is a direct
object reference which is fine there's
nothing wrong with that
but the fact that it doesn't enforce
authorization on that call that's the
problem it should have checked when i
asked for your gun information that was
actually you instead of me
and t-mobile didn't do that
in apis we don't call that insecure
direct object references anymore that
wasn't sexy enough so we call it bola
broken object level authorization which
is the same issue just with a different
name
and this issue
api security top 10 number
one thank you awesome people are waking
up so 9 30 first coffee is starting to
hit that's good so number one this
happens everywhere remember that study
from these apps in the uk the healthcare
apps 100 of apis had this exact
vulnerability and here's some more
examples in the patient portal
millions of patients health information
whoops
that's a mistake on twitter we
could allow well we could abuse a bug
like this to match phone numbers to
twitter accounts which is kind of
sensitive and then on facebook somebody
figured out how to use this
vulnerability to change the name of a
facebook page and then register a new
page with the same name so they could
hijack that url to the page
15 000 usd as a bug bounty just to show
you that this is not an insignificant oh
yeah thank you for reporting
vulnerabilities like an oh crap let's
pay the guys some money for having
reported that issue
happens everywhere
why
because of stuff like this
if you build your first node.js rest api
in 10 minutes i can tell you there's not
gonna be any security in there
and that's okay that's not
i mean you're joking you're laughing
with this but that's how we learn stuff
right if you want to learn how to build
an api on azure you're going to find a
tutorial from a blogger somewhere from
microsoft devrel and you're going to
follow that and 10 minutes later you
have deployed an api on azure and you're
like yeah awesome same thing here
there's nothing wrong with that
there's since no
stab at the author of this article this
is a valid article and it teaches you to
build something like this a to do
application of course
a to do application the common example
and it gives you an end point to delete
tasks like app dot delete that's a
restful method awesome slash task task
id and we can delete that task from the
system
no security that's okay
you're here to learn about rest not
about security so what's the next step
the next step is like okay how do we add
security to this api because we all know
that we have to do it and you're going
to find another tutorial that's going to
explain some kind of authentication
mechanism and you're going to add a
requires art decorator or whatever on
that call it's a middleware in express
or a decorator in python or whatever
you're doing in
spring or whatever
awesome
right now you're t-mobile
t-mobile checked if you were
authenticated when you asked your
account info it never checked who you
were so
you're already moving up in the world so
that's good
what else should you be doing well we're
deleting stuff so maybe we should check
if the user actually has permission to
delete a task
kind of makes sense right
so you find a way to do that you
implement that and that's actually kind
of um well done as well this is called
protection against functional level
alters or this is functional level
authorization
that was in the api scripted up then and
i don't know by heart which number i
think five if i'm not mistaken
function level authorization basically
checking if a user is allowed to perform
a certain operation in the system
very useful very important
a lot of people get this right actually
because it's it's very conceptually
straightforward to to analyze this to
think about this
however this snippet of code now
still has ebola vulnerability a broken
object level authorization issue why
because we check if you can delete tasks
you never check which task you can
delete like hey you can delete your task
or my task or that guy's task any id you
have and if it starts at 1 and ends at
nine hundred thousand nine hundred
ninety nine well you can kind of guess
what the other ids are gonna be
and that's okay there's no problem in
having predictable ids there's a problem
in having no object level authorization
you have to check whether something is
allowed or not
but we're not there yet so the first
takeaway here is implement function
level authorization very important this
permission-based approach kind of works
well to enforce function level
authorization it's intuitive and
somewhere you can map that permission to
a user's role or some other properties
that you like to enforce
awesome
that's checking if somebody can perform
a certain operation
now before we talk about object level
authorization i have a question for you
here's two examples from that to do
application
are these secure when it comes to
function level authorization we're not
talking about object level authorization
yet is this secure yes or no
is this good code
oh no the code probably isn't very good
because i paraphrase it for powerpoint
but is this secure
maybe right
who knows
is that the bottom has function level
authorization checks like has permission
delete task the top example has nothing
is that intentional
or did you just forget it
i don't know
that these are questions i asked during
security assessments i asked the team i
work with the deaf teams when i do that
and i ask them like what are you doing
there and they're like
yeah
i think that's supposed to be like that
like is that publicly accessible like
yeah we think so they have to call
someone like yeah yeah yeah that's okay
that's okay
why don't we make that explicit because
auditability is
the second most important property of an
authorization policy security is one
asset ability is second because you
can't have security without being able
to audit the policy
is this according to your policy yes or
no what if we would have written this
allow public access
which can just be like return true i
don't care what it does
but what i care about is this if you
look at this code at first glance it's
going to scream at you what it's doing
it's not like you have to look for
something that's missing to the the to
induce what the intent is here no it
says like hey man public access
and if this doesn't make sense if this
is like delete all users and it says
allow public access you can be like
no no let's not do that
seriously auditability is very important
and making things clear to understand
with things like this is useful
because now you can enforce additional
rules you can have a security
scanning rule in semgrap for example
that says every endpoint needs to have a
call to art
whether it's check permission public
access we don't care but if you write an
endpoint without such an object
you get a bad result you get a finding
in some graph and we refuse to build
that code that could be a solid policy
auditability you have to empower
auditability you have to force
yourself and your colleagues to write
code that is easy to audit because that
will be worth it in the long run you
seriously need to do that
all right
what about bola broken object level
authorization well if you want to fix
that you'll quickly
end up in a place where you really
really don't want to be
because it starts looking like this like
oh yeah you have to check permission
delete task
and then you have managers and employees
and this and this and a manager can
delete all tasks but employees can only
delete their own tasks so you start to
write code like if the user is an
employee then we have to apply this
additional check and it's going to be a
freaking nightmare
remember this auditability well now your
code is littered with crap like this
and then somebody says like hey what if
we add a new role in turn with some
additional requirements now you have to
go through your entire code base and be
like okay and if the user is an intern
then we apply this rule and that rule
and it's
it doesn't work and that's why broken
object level authorization is such a big
issue
making a single mistake in this
authorization logic
is enough to create a vulnerability
so how do we fix that well
take that crap out of your code sorry
that authorization policy out of your
code that thing doesn't belong in your
code you have to take it out
to ensure that you can audit that policy
again by taking it out we create
an authorization policy
you can call it a policy engine because
it sounds very cool it's like our policy
decision points it's like whoa awesome
it's just one place with rules for
authorization
it can be as simple as if you're
building a java app have a class
authorization and in that class you have
functions can delete task which returns
either true or false and that is your
policy decision point which is a very
fancy name for that that's how you sell
that to your boss like yeah plus we need
a policy decision point which is also a
policy information point
awesome
seriously i'm making jokes about this
but this is really important by
centralizing this logic
you you gain two things you gain
the ability to simplify your endpoint
code all of these checks go away it now
becomes authorization dot can delete
task
here's the task you want to delete
here's the user
what do you think
and it will give you true or false
exception no exception whatever works
for your language awesome
how do you audit this well first of all
you check that every endpoint calls the
policy
and then you look at the policy you can
literally look at the policy and be like
yeah that makes sense you want to change
something you change the policy
you want to see who messed up the policy
get to blame
very easy
it's all in one location it's seriously
it's something that you want to
centralize
that's the
how do i say this delicately the poor
man's policy decision point just a piece
of code that does all authorization
checks awesome
if you want to be fancy you can
externalize it in a service there's
services like open policy agent that
allow you to define a policy in a policy
language and run that as a service we
can ask that service like what do you
think about this what do you think about
that these things can be very advanced
very fine-grained down to the field
level like this user is allowed to
update that field on these types of
objects
that's what you can do with things like
this open policy agent is one example
ozo is actually gaining some traction as
well
it's a new approach
for doing authorization built by
developers
it's very new very
fresh so um it's not
widespread supported yet but it's
something interesting to keep an eye on
if you're interested in authorization
policies
all right
so encapsulate complex authorization
logic avoid having that scattered
throughout the code because it hurts
auditability it's going to make your
life a nightmare to maintain that and
it's virtually impossible to secure that
pull it out have it centralized
look at it have someone else look at it
make sure it makes sense write unit
tests of your policy that's another
benefit you can actually write tests
against your actual authorization policy
like can delete task here's a battery of
cases where it's supposed to be yes and
it's supposed to be no awesome
all right
let's keep going why not we have time
if you want to make authorization
decisions
you need to know one important thing
who's asking to do something
authentication is is often this huge
issue like yeah we have to have
authentication but it plays
the second file in it's only in function
of authorization nobody really cares
about who you are well except trackers
but
a normal application doesn't really care
who you are they care about what you're
allowed to do and to decide that they
need to know who you are and that's what
authentication really does
and user authentication is kind of this
very complex topic because the user
typically authenticates once to an
authentication service and after that we
propagate the user's authenticated state
clients authenticate often on every
request it's not uncommon for a client
to be like hey i'm that client do
something hey i'm that client do
something with the user well we struggle
with having users authenticate once
securely so let's keep it at once that's
that's fine use authenticate once and
then after that we have session
management
which is a dirty word in api world so
that's not called sessions let's call it
i don't know what we want to call it
seriously that's how we do user
authentication that's where we get the
authorization information and with that
we can make authorization decisions so
how do you do that in apis what about
using cookies
a j session id
wow
people are angry now i can see the looks
like
what no man
yes do it
it's awesome
seriously if you're building an api with
a few hundred or a few thousand users
and you're running this
yourself with your front end and your
api and you control all of this and it's
based on browser-based clients this is
really really awesome we've been using
it for more than 20 years and it works
i'm like yeah but we're doing cloud
stuff
we're cool we don't have application
servers like tomcat no we're deploying
stuff on heroku well good because heroku
has java session handling support with
the redis cache
and i know that this is a very unpopular
opinion but web sessions work
really well
they keep data on the server in a secure
location you don't have trust issues
with that data you get an identifier you
look up who the user is and you make
your authorization decision and you
handle whatever you want
and some people will argue but it's a
stateful backend but
that concept is
often over simplified i'm not saying
write stateful code i'm not saying that
your code should behave differently
based on what happened before your code
can be the same
you just take some information from a
server-side session object make your
decision and you're done and this works
very well for web-based apis
you can quote me on that
trust me i've done this talk very
quite a few times over the past few
years in various formats and after a
talk typically after meetup or
conference talk people come to me like
yeah that thing you said about sessions
yeah we switched all of that to token
based stuff and at the end we had no
benefit in doing that it was a major
effort for zero benefits this works
really well in traditional
settings small scale applications i'm
not saying do this if you have 15
million users because you're gonna
be hurting really fast but if you have a
small system like so many applications
this works really well
even though it's not going to get you
the cool vote from your colleague
developers
this works awesome
all right what do you do if you do not
want to use this
if you
don't want to use sessions but you want
to use tokens then you're very likely
going to end up in the oauth world
oh wow it is kind of designed to handle
cases like this we have an authorization
server where the user or the client can
authenticate or vote in some cases and
we get an access token from that
authorization server and we request
access with that access token an api is
going to use that access token to make
authorization decisions
that's a decoupled approach
better right people are happy again it's
like oh yes tokens thank you
fun fact you know what the bottom link
uses between the browser and that
authorization server
cookies
that's how you do single sign-on because
cookies work really well in browsers
that aside
so even when you're like yeah we're
using outfit tokens now you're also
using cookies trust me cookies are
always there on the web anyway access
tokens that's the api side of things we
don't care about the bottom link that's
whatever apis now get tokens
what type of tokens
this is going to be really funny by the
way what type of tokens well oat has two
types of tokens the first one is a
reference token
you know the reference token is
an id it's like a session id we just
call it a reference token because now
people can ignore that it's a session id
no seriously a reference token is a
random identifier pointing to states
kept by the authorization server so you
get that token we call it a token it's
not a child it's just a random id we
send it to the api and the api is like
oh thank you for that token i'm going to
ask that other service what it means oh
sorry i'm going to ask another service
what it means
almost like asking redis cash but let's
let's ignore that seriously that's what
a reference token does it's called token
introspection and the security people
love it
because it gives you very good security
properties like immediate revocability
hey if the user logs out well we revoke
the reference token at the authorization
server and it becomes invalid the user
wants to kill or terminate a session
like immediately because of a breach you
can revoke that reference token at the
authorization server and it goes away
immediately awesome
security people are like yeah reference
tokens
developers dealing with performance are
like
yeah
i'm not so sure about that because every
api request typically requires an
introspection call so that's a lot of
traffic that's going on so what's the
alternative that's the sexy alternative
the alternative here is self-contained
tokens which is well oit uses very
complex terms it's a fancy way of saying
it's a jot token json web token and a
self-contained token contains all the
information in the token it's signed you
send it to the api the api verifies the
signature doesn't have to call on anyone
to do that you can verify that
independently use the claims in the
token to make an authorization
decision question that often follows
from explanations like this is which one
do we use
i don't know it depends
it depends on what you're building
and that's the takeaway here
you have to understand your requirements
analyze your requirements
because some people are just helped with
the jsession id
seriously if you're building a
springboot api
it has built-in support for sessions you
can use that
it deploys well in a simple environment
for a few hundred or a few thousand
users it's gonna save you at least
at least two days to a week of
investigation time implementation time
to come up with an alternative it's
secure it works well it's reliable and
it's absolutely awesome
if you were in my workshop we have run
lab sessions on an api-based application
and that application i built up myself
uses server-side sessions because it's
easy
and i typically don't have millions of
users in my workshop because of physical
room constraints
people want to come in the millions no
that's not true
but you kind of get the idea
this is important by the way because
if you don't understand this if you're
just following what everybody else is
saying because that's what we do think
in modern applications for no good
reason then you're going to make things
more difficult for yourself without good
reason that's essentially what i'm
trying to say
but yeah that json web token that's
probably what you're going to use i know
that's what everybody else is using even
with out there like jason webb tokens
that's better
and in most cases it's not a not a bad
idea to use them by the way in this
image let me skip back for a second and
this image that token has less good
security properties because you can't
easily kill it if you want to
because it just lives out there
there's no control over that token when
it lifts that's why we keep the lifetime
short five to ten minutes is a good
recommendation
that reduces the window of abuse of that
token in case something goes wrong
somebody steals it five minutes only
so for most applications that would be
acceptable for some applications that
would even that is unacceptable think
about money stuff i probably don't want
to want that token lying around for five
minutes
if it gives access to money
all right
how do you handle that shot token
securely well if you wrote my talk
yesterday you know that we're not going
to be able to cover that in five minutes
so i'm not gonna do that i wrote a very
in-depth blog post for uh for 42 crunch
an api security company last december
and it's the blog post is just out there
so you can go to that link and read all
about shot security pitfalls and
recommendations to avoid that so go
there and enjoy that article
take away here is follow jot security
best current practices there's a whole
spec on that there's an rfc that
contains
the same information in maybe a less
digestible format but it's a very useful
document nonetheless
right
a battery of tests to make sure your
application handles jots securely if you
were here yesterday elk none test for
that
and make sure you handle jots securely
and that brings me to the last point
what happens when pull goes wrong i have
to watch my language here
well
too often
when something does go wrong when some
feature gets compromised when a breach
happens
the whole system comes crumbling down
like a house of
cards that's not necessary
that's
unfortunate
and unfortunately very very common
compartmentalize your applications
that's the takeaway here that's the
final takeaway compartmentalize your
apis split them up there's no reason to
have an authentication part of your api
sit right next to all the other
application features pull it out as a
separate service give it a separate data
store shield it protect it because it's
very sensitive
goes for the other things as well if you
have an image processing service which
is very untrustworthy it's very likely
that something will go wrong there
put it aside in a separate service
shield it on the network don't give it
access to databases don't give it access
to data
and maybe just as a precaution kill it
like every day and boot it up again to
be sure
who knows but compartmentalization will
eventually save you if something goes
wrong
and that's what we want to do in the end
to make things more secure
all right now it's up to you i've done
my part i told you what to do that's the
fun part of my job i can just be like
that's what you got to do bye-bye
so now it's up to you so i'll get your
api authorization policy i can guarantee
you well probably on monday but i know
how things go i can guarantee you that
we will find something
almost guaranteed
let me know about that it's always fun
to hear that the stuff i'm doing is
actually relevant so if you find
something just send me a message or
shout out on twitter like yeah thank you
we find a vulnerability right security
tests for jots make sure you handle them
securely write that open api
specification look into these tools that
use them
and see how you can use them to
systematically improve your security
all right if you want to learn more i
have some online course content on api
security os openly connect react
security and so on you can also hire me
to come to your company i'll gladly talk
for two days about security topics or
three or four if you want to
but that's going to blow up your head
and with that i want to thank you for
being here enjoy the rest of the
conference here and if you have anything
you want to talk about shout out me on
twitter or linkedin or grab me here at
the conference all right thank you very
much